citizens of the reject Nation it is time
for the Tim show Monarch Legacy of
monsters episode what what episode are
we on I think we're on episode eight
doesn't matter it's in the title it's a
all righty guys well you know what I
don't Hae when you guys answer me this
specific question who would you rather
have as a sibling Kate or canaro leave
it in the comments below and be very
descriptive as to why you would choose
one of them you have to choose yeah none
of this neither stuff anyway guys leave
a like that would be very much
appreciated Roar that subscribe
notification Bell thanks to prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
full length Reaction watch alongs where
you syn up with your own copy of Monarch
Legacy of monsters it's available for
our super sexy rejects it's over at our
patreon page it's the best place that's
where John and Greg cover several shows
exclusively with highlights and watch
alongs included and I say let's just get
our ciry Clemens on let's do it do this
Clemons let's
go you're just mad because he takes
after me of course I am it's not fair we
Riot Russell's POV he's obviously got
your Brands and he'll be blessed with my
gravity defying breaking curveball is
this where the camera is I guess so look
your brains my arm It's the Best of Both
Worlds ah they're talking about their
dad by their dad I mean the present
kid's dad their son kentaro and K
we
we whoa he misses her so much damn that
was like the first romantic scene
between her and Andre's home she's got
to be alive he seems so downtrod I feel
like she's alive if he's got special you
know ageless Juju je she must too we've
recently had some very promising results
with our gamma simulation techniques it
would appear
so my hats off to you Captain we to
please so much scientific gibberish it
might as well be Chinese algebra on used
it to cphon off resources that ought to
be used to safeguard this great nation
we are trying to safeguard the world
they think they're full of [__] so you
think that Godzilla respects National
boundaries our nuclear superiority
proved more than a match for Godzilla
and I'm confident it will again should
need toise oh boy 2 years since Castle
Bravo you have provided not a shred of
evidence to suggest that possibility
damn dude and you haven't found Bigfoot
either I see one of your breakthroughs
based on technology developed by a
former officer in the Imperial Japanese
Navy Dr meura here ever qualified for a
top secret clearan is beyond me wow dude
given the juicy tidbits the FBI turned
up and her background check you son of a
[__] what did they find we're all in
love with
[Music]
her welcome to Monarch
Tim Tim makes me feel like I'm in the
TVA Tim is the Mobius of Monarch your
grandfather became obsessed started
pushing all these theories about
teleportation and wormholes real tinfoil
Hat type of stuff real [__] we're
never going to see Ever to get fitted
for our temp4
hats your freak flag fly
bro Karo you got the best lines fly that
freak flag this is your legacy this is
more like it Legacy of the control room
Monarch has outposts all over the world
right now they are picking up gamma
rapers just like we saw before gday
Alaska North Africa places we know your
father has been maybe he's leaving all
the gamma radiation is he predicting
them or is he following them good
questions we do qu questions really well
around here but what we need right now
are some answers yeah oh my God sh was
talking to us meta we don't know exactly
what Shaw is trying to accomplish here
but if he sets off another blast it
could push it over the line so that
means another GD I'd rather not find out
that's why you're here it sounds like
sha wants the monsters to conquer uh-oh
we need to know where Shaw's heading to
Next he dumped Us in the desert stole
the map and took off with your partner
you saw hoshi's map it let you to
Godzilla Tim seems to think that your
bloodline gives you some unique insight
into the situation wow you're the
specials so I need you to think about
your father about this map that he made
and about where it's leading Shaw God
what a long lens they chose for
this the
bloodline yeah so they have some like
real special DNA with powers I've been
telling you man what exactly do you
think we'll find in there
[Music]
R
whoa it won't be for the faint of heart
I can tell you that some traumatic
memories coming back I can't believe
that crap he said about you juicy
tidbits what a load of racist
horeshit hey not bad dude how's your
hand feel not great well it's the first
punch I've ever
thrown I need you guys to start making a
map a map he wants to know where the
Titans are hiding let's draw my goddamn
map the map build me a case for Monarch
all those field notes and the journals
and the diaries that you've been keeping
what we know about the Titans where they
where they sleep what they eat spawn
mate the whole shoting match I want to
know where eat I want to know where they
sleep going a little stir crazy in here
or I inherited that from someone with a
temper keep filling out uh maintenance
request inherited that from their
grandpa July 7 2008 it was my 18th
birthday hey my dad was here doing a
software update on the geosynchronous
Titan anomaly sensing system
gas yeah
cheetas this was his mission was it it
was his life we're not going to find him
with some multispectrum satellite sweep
wait did you find something yeah at the
top of this box in the first page of
this F operative loss during field
assignment and performance of Duties
missing presumed killed
Koo okay Monarch cost us our father and
both our grandparents wait missing
presume killed she's alive she's alive
in the hollow Earth baby that's what I'm
thinking I'm thinking Hollow Earth
living cuz in the Godzilla xong tra
there are people there maybe she's
involved with them that's racist John
cuz they're all
Asians it was on hiroshi's map places
we're seeing a spike in Gamay admissions
yes one of it's where he lost her when
we were in the desert the way he talked
about our grandmother I thought he was
going to tell me he was our grandfather
oh that's what we're all waiting for
Shaw is trying to rewrite the past to do
that he needs to go back to the place
where everything went to hell for him
back to the streets we began feeling as
good as Monster Hunters can W go I am
not sending a bunch of untrained
amateurs after Lee Shaw they've been
amazing you sent a bunch of trained
professionals last time how did that
work out for you oh you got to go
against the grain we can be your double
agents I'll go with them look they're
randa's kids yeah we got found a
portfolio I mean that was me right
screwed dad he screwed us I understand
if you need to leave I'm not leaving but
I'm not cleaning up his mess I'm not
doing this for him I'm just going to
stand here why do all their scenes sound
the same literally moments ago in the
prove me wrong what joke moments ago
when they were all in the big controller
I was like I think I'm finally starting
to like this entire ensemble and then
they stepped into the hall and I was
like God damn it this the same exact
kind of see you did dialog delivery
there is second third fourth hand
accounts with no corroborating EV sound
CCH would you like to lose the other
hand they haven't fallen in love yet
right no they got their kiddo clearly
CHS are mission hatch and Pucket right
so that's what I did this is more like a
blueprint of a house that's designed by
a hundred different Architects are we
ignoring the bugs you got stairways
going nowhere rooms with no doors and
you end up with a house that's bigger on
the inside than on the
outside clean up after yourself H how'
you manage to get ants four stories
underground there a sign the hell was
that bag I don't know beyond logic lies
the truth yes but hatch and Pucket can't
see the possibilities in the impossible
the way you do the way we do a Beyond
logic lies my heart Billy I'm
thank you for what you did up there it
was stupid but thank you got my back
look the nerve that guy coming at you
like that yeah but what hatch said it
wasn't the truth is there are things in
my life in my past that I haven't shared
with you I I don't care I don't care
what you do from the day that I met you
when you wouldn't leave me on the wreck
of the laden I knew I knew that I had to
protect you that I could trust you and
no matter what John I think this is the
part of the timeline where they haven't
done anything yet oh I guess so keep up
we started the episode with them talking
about Hiroshi so much going on I guess
the job here is to make it simple enough
to understand so that even uh
Neanderthal could understand it English
please you're in the Philippines you can
eliminate the Siberian reports what no I
had three independent sources two drunk
one
blind next okay uh you blurry photos
photos nah he called out blurry photos
Monarch Legacy of Love Monarch Legacy of
adorability oh
sh oh you getting bitter dog you getting
bitter very
nice Borat has ruined
Kazakhstan yep Shaw escalated this yeah
and he's going to do it again if he sees
you at least talk to us what makes you
think listen we are Roshi's kids because
he wants us here he wants someone to
take over the family business and he
thinks we're the only family he has left
he's not can shoot us it's okay you guys
got this he'll listen to you I think
it'd be so funny if Kurt Russell just
shot them both right in the head I would
have done it sooner too but looks like
you were right he's already here I feel
like the ending scene is going to be the
reveal that she's still alive I could
see that for sure
to keep us hooked to con in next week's
episode oh dude spoilers I think the
final shot is going to be of whatever
was in that damn bag with the bugs in it
y'all sure you want to do
this guess so I guess why not you know
what else are we going to
do are they supposed to be The
Goonies yeah this is just a shot for
shot remake of The Goonies now cuz if
they're supposed to be The Goonies I
never watch watch The
Goonies Yep this whole show has just
been a primer for your Goonies
experience aren't you
[Music]
excited oh the
Reds what kind of exposure are we
looking at about 210 of a Miller is that
bad bad adjacent it's not good this
place supposed to be uninhabitable for
Thousand Years monster Chernobyl
something's absorbing the radiation ah a
Gateway or someone they're Dad yeah it's
just shiroshi down there just absorbing
all sorts of radiation and then vomiting
into Kaiju mouths like a mama
bird don't move what is it what is it
what is it I'm not
moving it's like
molted oh no that's it's a shelf
yeah it's empty you're fine shed its
skin it's exoskeleton it's an
exoskeleton like when an insect MTS Tim
just learned what that was jeez Tim
entomology
much
gross please let's never see
them we're at six M SS now this is where
they lost Koo and this is where he'll be
but where is
he
[Music]
oh sweet
wowe jump yeah toss something down there
jump It's a portal it's an entry point
to where tinfoil
Hatland and we didn't pack any foil is
Chara's plan really that crazy to try
and close it maybe he doesn't want to
close it maybe he wants to go in you
think he's going to go in he's going to
go in after he better go in charges
settle around the perimeter
looks like look like have to bring this
whole place down CL yeah you're right
can you diffuse them you can try looks
like they're rigged her radio Detonator
step away from the
hey reunion it's me Tim it's Tim
shouldn't be here Tim you're not cut out
for field work sure about that maybe I
learned a thing or two from you a
where's Shaw you finally made it I've
been waiting for you this means you want
to talk talk let's talk was waiting back
there till I heard your voice
Kate just you not hosi I mean not not
canaro you know what I mean all Asian
people are the same stairs to nowhere
he's really not bothered by that book
we're on the stairs to Nowhere what the
hell are we missing stop missing with
the
ant
[Music]
whoa
ha figer on the inside the ants right
the Tardis I know how you are about your
privacy you can't be here oh no who's
here the guy who's been terrible
monarchic person of course the ants
showed me it's bigger on the inside what
are you talking about what if they live
underground the Titans if that's how
they move around the world without being
seen like ants yes gigantic ants what if
it's another realm not just beneath the
Earth but Hollow Earth yes inside but
also alongside oh
existing together
[Music]
ooh mama uh-oh this is my son
hos oh so he adopted him I guess so it's
why I applied to do my postgraduate work
at Berkeley after the war I I wanted
hero to have other opportunities
then I couldn't bring him in the
beginning jeez who's the father I just
didn't realize how long it was going to
take for me to bring him I was finally
able to save up enough money thanks to
the jobat Monarch oh you see how I'm
treated a woman a Japanese what do you
think they'd do if they found out I was
a widow trying to raise a child alone oh
boy then don't do alone oh have shammer
he seems really Gaga for you why just me
you know why you looked into his eyes
he's not just a Mindless destructive
force nope he knows what he's doing and
what's that protecting us there's a
world down there Kate and it's not ours
A I know because I've been to it you
been to it flashback it exists Kate
Billy and KO were right please please
believe me that's how he aged slow or
whatever what did you see tell me what
they couldn't believe it's really hard
to get to the hollow Earth though he's
not here to hurt us he's just keeping
his kind in their world and Us in ours
so that's why you want to seal off their
world I am sealing off their world but
the sequels don't worry John this is a
prequel somewh no
dude what makes you so sure that your
data whatever that might be is so right
it's not about the data cake it's all
about belief oh hey that is different
than data I'm do before the Vice
President in about 2 minutes sadly
there's nothing in Lieutenant hatch's
Illuminating report to justify the
continued funding of project Monarch oh
it's a map sir a comprehensive
projection of all the potential Titan
threats currently under assessment by
project Monarch Jesus Christ you did not
give
up sir I believe that you'll find
lieutenant hatch's report has omitted
certain facts to justify shifting
funding from Monarch to his own
priorities oh such as Godzilla sir
that's highly classified why would he
have that in this file we didn't kill
it oh boy I just feel compelled to point
out that this was not provided by
Lieutenant hatch but through the sole
dedication diligence and loyalty of
doctors mea and
Randa absolutely I do hope that drir
rand's position as sole authority of a
project monarch scientific operations
will remain unchallenged and that hatch
will be called a [__] he's lost
Michelle sha he doesn't know what he's
doing he knows exactly what he's doing
and at least he's not sitting around him
waiting to see what happens next all you
people do is sit on your hands Koo she
was the first one to jump in against my
better judgment my mission was to
protect her my mission to protect you I
know this is where you lost her sounds
like she was a force of nature this is
to make up for losing her isn't
it well of course it is smart kid clear
the
space oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy get out everybody
out oh
no oh
God they going fall in maybe he should
have run this by the team oh my God cor
no but Kate loves her oh [__] oh my God
it's like a
beetle
[Music]
whoa oh no how did cor survive this I
don't
know whoa everyone's going in jump on it
kentaro kentaro's like I don't want to
go do I
[Music]
go oh yeah damn was not the wrong we're
both wrong the ants were definitely more
important
yeah it's good yeah man I like when ants
find the clues you have to follow the
bug see where it goes that's all you had
to do and then it'll tell you the answer
to what you're looking for
that's all dad did he just watched bugs
walk all over his graphs and Maps he
watched the ants oh no Kora you fallen
in what do I do to get you
out I don't know why dad was here I
don't even want to go on this adventure
but I guess I
will sha isn't
there he's going to blow it
[Music]
up so good right it's all dude you're
you could be in the in Monarch I could
have been in Monsters you could be in
the show I'm here to audition for
Monarch Legacy of monsters I'm going to
play the sun really bent about my dad I
used to be an artist now I'm not anymore
cuz I didn't like the
[__] and now I got my sister who I
hate but I follow around
everywhere even though all my dialogue
is mostly about how I don't want to do
this I don't even want to be here just
want to go home to
Japan with my mom who's one of the best
characters on the show that's a good
joke John thanks thank you the joke is
good we should remember that for the
future I'm not here to make jokes I just
want to review the
[Music]
episode take this seriously
Greg I am me too what you think of the
episode I liked it I liked this episode
did you did you think it was the best
one we've had so far might be it's one
of the better ones best I don't know if
it's the best one but it's one of the
good ones last one was easily the best
yeah that's true that's true I mean the
Tim episode is always going to reign
supreme but this could be like top four
out of eight so
far this could be number four in the top
four out of eight I don't know I don't
know where I would rank it it's not as
good as a Tim episode episod but I like
this episode and this
one uh you know I got a little maybe
confused with which point in time we
were at in different parts of the
flashbacks but maybe maybe most
definitely I definitely got confused I
says yeah I said to you John well that
first scene they're in the car and
they're like talking about they have a
kid and I was like no that's not it John
but they're talking about Hiroshi aren't
they they're talking about a kid of some
kind yeah some random ass kids but that
was in Kurt Russell's flashback when he
was in the truck and then Michelle
interrupted his flashback that's right
that's hey that's very good attention to
visual storytelling and we were in the
POV of him that's true in the flashback
her Russell wasn't in the room with them
yeah in fact I don't know whose POV
flashback were watching there I think
we're just watching a flashback just
watching oh no wait he was watching them
he was he dropping on them sure in the
yeah before he comes out and is like
Kate you talk to me yeah yeah he's
listening to all that he's just chilling
back there he's like waiting for the
right queue to come
out he was touching himself you know
love story yeah and because they fell in
love he made aous
decision and he's like I'm telling the
general about
about how Godzilla's alive because you
don't love
me and I'm mad at that and I'm going to
spitefully make sure that you and Bill
both are are elevated with me so that
you can never fully detach yourselves
from me because I did this this is going
to get you killed now I made the
sacrifice that made Monarch what it is
she so alive the show could not be more
obvious she's very much alive she's
coming back I would be more surprised if
she's not alive she won't have aged a
day I don't think she's aged
no how long were they in Hollow Earth
for how' they get to Hollow Earth I
don't know I mean she got a lot of
question I have cuz I thought Hollow
Earth was like this really difficult
thing to Traverse to get into and like
are they going against the rules in
Godzilla I didn't think you could just
fall into it well I wonder if we see K
get taken away by that like pile of
roached things so I don't know maybe
like they shielded her from whatever
boundaries there are I don't know I
don't and I don't know how that would
account for Shaw getting through or
coming back or coming back yeah I don't
understand any of this John none of it
makes any sense and it won't the show's
over it's done it's the last do so what
was your favorite part about it my
favorite part about it uh Tim always
good Tim uh I liked the scenes in the
past especially
between Anders Holm and the actress who
plays K right liked uh their little
intimate scenes together we've gotten a
lot of the shaw perspective on that
romance triangle and this episode was
one I think the first one that really
focused on Randa and K uh uh miora
having romantic chemistry together so
yeah I liked all those sweet little
moments and even though it's a you know
it's a vers
of the you know poking a pencil to the
paper thing like I thought the ants were
fun like you know that something's going
to come out of that and I thought that
was fun um I guess that was my my
favorite aspect of the episode and then
I mean seeing them I I did you know
being at Monarch being with you know
everybody trying to figure all this
stuff out you know when you have our
main characters in that environment I I
was with it I was enjoying it there
really just that one scene where they go
back into the hallway where Kate and
canaro talking the hallway and I was
like oh yeah this is the stuff I don't
like about this show but the rest of it
was was all pretty engaging pretty
fun and uh and yeah this was one that
felt like Monsters and Titans are
looming even though you don't see tons
of them you do get the one at the end
but even like with the moled husks the
exoskeletons and stuff all that was neat
it's pretty
cool what was your favorite aspect of
the episode Greg
uh all the stuff that you said that was
your favorite was easily my favorite hey
I still find the 50s flashbacks the most
compelling absolutely um yeah I
mean I am so absorbed into the monster
verse as it is that the immediacy of the
journey is kind of just rais this one
was one of those episodes where
connectivity raised questions for me and
I found myself a little distracted by
that sure cuz I'm like well all this
stuff about like sealing off Hollow
Earth and consequences of that well I'm
fully aware that we just we have a big
big movie incoming yeah he's kind of
like um he's like Shaw's kind of like
the reversal of Vera forga from don't
yawn hold it never yawn during your
monologue G hold it in hold it
in I drive to the top of the Laurel
Kanye mountain and yawn before you show
up to make sure I got that out of my
system and no one is in sight and then I
drive back here that's why I'm like I'm
running a little bit behind cuz I had to
go yawn someplace go to the furthest
point respectful to the highest peak you
don't think I want to Y look how tired I
look I can barely keep my eyes open on
camera you're perpetually tired wow
that's rude Oh I thought you were going
to say I was racist that's rude it's
also rude it's not racist good Asian
people are always WI awake yes so what's
your excuse or at least what's half of
your
excuse anyway John yeah or should I say
ywn that was a good one got there puns
he's the inverse of Vera fora yeah Vera
fora is like I want all the tit End To
Rule and Reign and I think we could live
a much better life that way cuz I'm
smart and I definitely know what's best
for my child yeah and instead of keeping
them in their world and Us in ours let's
just let's just let them have all of it
and and Shaw is Kurt Russell's a rather
compelling character is this man who you
know he's he's always like Mr carismatic
guy but underneath all that Charisma is
a lot of pain of loss of Bill loss of
Kiko KO Koo loss of
Koo and you know uh decisions that were
made consequences and he he he lives
with all that and now he's trying to
make amends he's atoning he's on a path
of of atonement but is this path of
atonement the right
choice you know or is he being clouded
by his own personal feelings so I think
there's a lot of very interesting
character stuff that they're doing with
him
absolutely um yeah I mean look we can't
go a video without mentioning I think
Kaden and T still two very boring
characters man like what the hell
happened with them in this episode yeah
you know Kate scene where Kurt Russell's
good but who's the interesting character
there Kurt Russell Russell I mean Kurt
Kurt Russell's there to be like yeah I
looked at Godzilla in the eyes yes he
saw me and I saw him and she steps in to
be like there will be no murder today
yeah that because I am embracing my
character Arc I think is what is I'm
accepting of my
legacy I really wanted some catharsis
from that moment I don't know what my
role is
exactly yeah something about my blood
and Monarch and I really wish that would
pay off so that we could get you guys
more vitally involved in this plot I
kind of like them back and forth thing
in the truck about like he's not going
to shoot us he wants us here I thought
that was okay that was when I was like
he's not going to shoot us that's the
one time Cano's dejected same delivery
seems purposeful yes true
agree and I mean this was perhaps I mean
Kurt Russell has always been like good
but this was an episode where I was like
oh okay I could feel like the the how
the old how the the you know 50s version
of you became this guy I could feel the
history here yeah um but I think in
terms of getting distracted by
connectivity I was like I'm not not
really sure what I still am waiting for
this show to be
like all right you've really contributed
something to the World building yeah
something fresh and vital and and
important that'll come up in Godzilla
XCOM like look how Apex came to be yeah
I was
really really scratching at the dog how
this happen how is there an apex who
would come up with a company that makes
Tech like that what it's not possible
really need to know got to know and
terms of Hollow Earth stuff uh yeah it's
if anything what they what the show's
Mor I think the show's done really well
in terms of
connectivity is the most subtle thing
they've done is how how much they have
recontextualized John Goodman's
character yeah true who just gets like
funly off in Kong Skull Island
yeah yeah the guy who gets killed at one
I try to forget about that stuff just
going to die I know he's just going to
have a death
scene you know hey maybe this will if
you took everything you see in this show
put it in Timeline order leading to that
scene where he dies you be like man
that's how he goes man what a bummer wow
how unceremonious that unceremonious
death they gave this
guy but anyway yeah that's just that um
about think life is though that is how
life is and if there's one thing this
mon show does
is life um so there's that and
uh K C Clemens is
fine I don't understand this thing about
their blood and connect they keep
talking about it blood Juju I think I
think they're more like a good luck coin
that Tim carries around with him I
didn't want to say fortune cookie cu
that would have sound very racist sure
that actually would have sounded racist
yes even though that was just the
metaphor I was looking for um it would
have sounded racist if I said good luck
fortune cookie that's
true good thing that you acknowledged
that good thing I acknowledge it thus
thwarting racism another day yeah I did
I beat it um but it it is they are just
kind of like a goodlook um token to keep
around you know yeah because they don't
really do anything other than
hey I stumbled upon this piece of
information that was just right here in
front of me
wow for people who look at their data
and then re recheck their data all the
time like you would think that they
would be great at catching stuff like
this just there' be like these Rand kids
are the key yes they got special Rando
blood they know stuff that we don't know
they're uncovering things they got some
special connection to all this their
Monarch blood
it's about belief now it's not about
science anymore John we've entered the
territory of spiritualism with the
monsters it's all the above they're
going to worship Godzilla in the next
one uh so yeah there's that I mean I
think this was a I I probably ranked
this as like the third or fourth best
honestly I would agree you said this was
the best I didn't I did I said it was
the absolute best he said it was the
best I said it was one of the best said
not better than Tim and you're like well
not better than Tim I said one of I
didn't say it was the bad I definitely
did not say it was the bad you said it
was better than every episode and all
the reacher episodes I definitely said
that this happens when someone is forced
to yes and a you can't get them to ever
grow a back you know Screw you buddy I
said no such thing they don't defend
themselves yes and I'm going to re-edit
the the part where I said one of the
best into this after this point so that
people know face facts Tim you you I the
Tim of the real you CED it away you are
the Tim of the real rejects yeah I'm not
fori I'm the canaro and
Kate and uhz I just want way better
character than either of them combined
no no but you are the chosen one I guess
no all I do is whine and speak dry
you're
Koo yeah man no Koo she's wonderful oh
yeah it was koo's uh husband who's the
real father the real bloodline Dad it's
not in the dad jeans we keep looking at
the dad's DNA it's all in the mom oh my
God Monarch's woke Mother Earth mother
nature mother Titan Monarch mother of
Legacy Legacy of Mother's momark Legacy
of
M Legacy of mommies Legacy of
mommies oh God that's really where the
legacy is we keep looking at the male
DNA yeah but that's why we're going from
Grandma to Kate the greatest characters
yeah from Kate Kate to Kate Kate gotta
love Kate gotta love her gotta love
Kate you know we've over this we don't
need to go over it again been over
this' been over this they're boring they
they really are they don't live up to
their grandmother they don't
exceptionally far more interesting
character and when they try to assert
themselves into like operations where
people have guns and stuff like that I'm
always like I feel like I'm in the
middle of some kind of what is their
Ling experiment what are they rising to
tell me sh what what is have they've
been
rejecting their their Destiny their
lineage
their their place in the world of
Monarch yes have they been lost and I
don't know where I belong yes what is
there what is it that they are arcing
into cuz I'll tell you it's right now it
is an empty vessel to me they're arcing
from normal people to people who go on
adventures John a real Arc
Baby John please don't mock me I would
never I'm asking a genuine question to
the camera mock art and I'm expecting an
answer any moment now okay I'll be quiet
I'll be quiet just in case we don't want
to miss
it you don't think I want to
yawn you don't think I want to yawn you
can get the biggest yawn out at the very
end of this you don't think I want to
yawn you don't think I've been sitting
here dozing off for the last 45 minutes
how DiCaprio would do it I want to
[__] ya
for the past 40 minutes I've been here
trying to pay attention to this show
about this brother sister Asian Dynamic
and you don't think I want to
yawn I'm yawning in my head all through
this
conversation slipped a little wallberg
there but what's like to
see I want Leo in the show now I'm
intense yeah I'm do do the squinty Le
the dumb Dum D sou guy
bubling guy who gets overwhelmed
sometimes and I start to
yell yeah those is the two best Leo Leo
types the Leo the Leo the range of Leo
yeah man Southern leading man in control
with power or stupid southern
guy yeah yeah yeah gets used in taking
advantage of yeah and then it all
coalesces into Calvin candy where he's
both he both characters is he really a
man of power there or is he also kind of
a joke John oh
both both to your
point yes and but but no they're
important they're arcing they're people
I gave this episode a 6.9 out of 10
sure seven I'll give it I'll give an
extra
0.1 go to seven yeah I felt bad for Tim
and Michelle or whatever yeah I think it
was I think it was nowhere near his ENT
I think like you get more of the monster
verse no I think the last one's more
monster verse still yeah you get the tie
in Apex and how that came to be and and
how Monarch came from the Shadows into
the light yeah to how a podcast would
one day be formed that should be the
closing shot this of Brian Ty when
they're like hey Brian Ty Henry's
character name and you're like and then
he turns around and you see his face and
he's like I want to start a podcast at
Apex let people know smash to play smash
the black yeah dude I love it I love it
and now we have the connective tissue
between king of the monsters and
Godzilla versus Kong uh I
needed yeah I I think
um it's good it's good plot mechanics
man this should have been a b show I'm
just saying I don't think this should
have been a B I don't think it should
have been a week to week show I don't
even love I don't even like to say that
about stuff but this does feel like it
would probably be more satisfying it
would 100% be more satisfying as a binge
and uh cuz yeah I mean like this kind of
episode was uh is cool little tidbits of
information really serious but I I did
prefer the flavor of last episode a lot
more I was like oh my God we're on the
up up yeah we're crusting into the
crescendo to end the season ending off
with the bang I love just how they other
than last episode how they'll do this
like one second tidbit of a monster
every time yeah yeah it just put one at
the very end it often feels like Apple
Studio note or legendary being like we
got to do it we got to there's some
produ that's the producer's contribution
whoever that producer was on set it was
like um you know I think we need a
monster in here to make audiences think
this is a show about monsters you know
maybe I don't know it might be a
valuable asset to our monster show it
it's not even about like the monsters
within here Humanity why is it called
Legacy of monsters it's just about how
Monarch um that would be a compelling
debate but the story of how Monarch came
to be if you really think about
it is so basic it is it is a very basic
story oh we discovered some Titans we
formed a little military group someone
in the military at one point wasn't a
big fan of it tried shutting it down but
now some evidence we found some evidence
and we kept the operation
going and they flirt with the idea that
like oh maybe they are monsters of
humanity cuz like oh this hbomb didn't
work we're going to build even bigger
hbomb that's kind of it and they're like
look how Wolverine found his jacket you
know yeah dude that's what a lot of a
lot of it is that's that's how I feel
about so much of what we learned I don't
like things where I don't know every
circumstance of how they came to be you
know
I'm so back and forth in this show what
do you mean I mean John Legacy of
yawns as we've talked about it and I
thought about this episode a little more
I was like I think I liked it a little
less than I think I did oh are you
offended I am good because yeah I'm so
sad I'm really just so back and forth on
on this show yeah CU you can just
constantly see all the potential cuz cuz
they have so many good assets organized
and the writing is it is it is so is
veryy by the numbers of how everything
is even in the 50s story which I still
find to be way more
intriguing it's pretty basic when you
think about it of how it all goes down
it's just significantly better it's all
that mindbending like I was talking uh
on the on the podcast I with heavy
spoilers I was just Point got brought up
I was talking about director's cuts and
how sometimes a director's cut can be
manipulative because a theatrical
version can be so bad and a director's
cut can be better and it can naturally
make your mind
go oh this movie is now good only
because it's better sure right like
Rebel moon will be like the rebel Moon
director yeah once both parts once both
parts that have been hacked down
he said Zach Zack SN said the director's
cut feels totally different and so I'm
like did he I don't understand why you
released whatever we don't need we don't
need to dive into that John that's all a
story for another day that I'm looking
forward to having with Zack snd fans yes
so too
the now I'm not and I think the 50 story
genuinely has some really great stuff in
there yeah I think that when you pull
back and and look at it you're
like but there's not really anything
that
like I don't know it's just it feels
very by the numbers when you think about
it yeah there's just not as much to it I
keep coming back to the JJ Abrams
Mystery Box thing and I know that there
are good examples of him executing that
but it does feel like that to me where
it's like they create this air of
mystery and they create these obstacles
and stuff and she even says this at one
point in this episode was like we're
good got questions we're good questions
and I don't even feel like we have that
many questions I feel like the show
could have been like four episodes it
does feel like that it feels like it's
been stretched out I feel like we're
watch you know when they would do like
viral videos they would shoot like
extended viral videos to expand on like
they would do that for they a lot like
Prometheus and alien Covenant yeah like
there's a whole scene with James Franco
that exists for an alien Covenant viral
video that is not in the movie that's
kind of what I feel like we're watching
here just a super long version of that
sure this could have been we episodes or
something like that yeah it feels like
some that's what I feel like we're
watching a very long version of that
where occasionally the episode comes
along with like that that was really
like the last episode I iode really did
it for me I really liked that last
episode a lot and this one just kind of
brought me back to yeah it's fine the
the last episode was was fun in a
different way and dramatic in a way that
coalesced properly ly whereas an episode
like this I think wants to have more of
a somber tone because of you know this
the the struggles being presented and
the truths being revealed about like oh
K's got this kid and she's a widow and
blah blah uh and and it only in some of
those flashback scenes it gets close but
I feel like in an episode where they
want to go more downtrodden and more
burdened by all these things they're not
as good at that like when they do go
towards fun it works better because so
partly this should be fun to some extent
but uh it's
not
I it's not that I want this to be deep
but it doesn't feel like there's an
appropriate amount of depth to what
they're trying to do much of the time no
and it doesn't have to again it can it
would be more intriguing if they were
like 10-minute videos that left you
Desiring ooh they should make a series
yeah
where like I I and then they make the
series and you go they should have just
thought this as a viral video yeah as
web episodes it's like I would like to
at least walk out of these with that
feeling of like damn I got I got a I got
so many question like that's that's why
we end up talking for so long because we
keep trying to find the good cuz it's us
and you know like we like unless we're
like doing a straight out of the theater
movie review where we're like we're on a
time crunch here we got to be blunt we
got to be blunt we got no choice we got
to be blunt because we are getting
kicked out of here soon with these we
talk forever here because we spend the
first like 15 minutes trying to be like
nice and then as we keep going we start
realizing you know what maybe we didn't
like it as much as we think we do I just
wish this show had better writing I
don't know it's weird and with all the
all the credits they have on it's not
weird it's a perfectly reasonable ass
John Yeah well yeah and like for for the
for for what this is I don't think it's
that you have people like Matt fraction
and Matt shackman involved and I get
Matt shackman is more on the film side
fraction more on the comic book side but
like those are people who seem
like perfect to help Shepherd something
like this along with whoever else they
have assembled it's so fascinating to me
that that yeah like it's just fun and
intriguing enough to where like I do
find stuff I enjoy about it each time
keep saying the word fun and I don't
understand how you you say that word so
often and I I'm just not there with you
I on that adjective specifically it's
not that I think the show itself is very
fun say it's fun enough it's fun I'm
like I still have fun I'm like you have
fun I have to like be like keep paying
attention cuz I am I'm not as invested
as I I would like to check my phone sure
I'm beused I I don't think the show is
is all that fun itself for what it is
doing uh I that's just me being like I
I'm happy to be here watching a Godzilla
thing even if it's not not a great
Godzilla thing you know like it's it's
fun enough and by that I mean it's not
aggravating at least most of the
time uh no it's a very passive show NE
it's fun in the sense that it's neat I'm
always like oh cool like I'm always here
for the setup and I always feel like
whether or not they'll deliver the
punchline or the payoff you know is is
way hit or miss but I'm always slightly
bemused by what we're here to do we're
walking dead got to in later Seasons I
feel like we got here by episode like
three God but I would so kill for like
more random scenes of let's just pair
these two off and make them talk for a
minute let's pair these two off and make
them talk for a minute like I I'll take
that cuz like I I don't know like this
one of these episodes is interesting
because this episode is more action
oriented uh than some of the other ones
uh what do you mean action oriented well
you know you're on both timelines and
people are moving around a lot and it's
like oh I got to you know we we got to
run across the world to Kazakhstan and
we got to go to Monarch and we got to go
find Sha and then in the past it's like
oh you know randa's got to run over here
to Kay's place and then they got to talk
from it and then Shaw's got to run over
to the military guy and it's like we're
doing a lot we're doing a lot of stuff
in an episode like this uh and I mean it
did have at least one or two nice
emotional beats but I feel like you
trade one for the other you either trade
for an episode where it's like all right
we're going to have a bunch of Dow
repetitive scenes of these two kids not
agreeing about how to proceed on this
adventure or we're going to do one of
these where you know we're doing a bunch
and we're going all sorts of places and
then the impact is maybe lesser because
all right look man it's late and I got
to keep editing we will never fully
Artic I got to go listen uh guys what do
you think about this episode would you
rather have canaro or Kate as your
sister or brother I don't think I forgot
about that yeah buddy and uh listen
we'll talk with everyone uh really
really soon uh thank you very much uh
bye last two episodes are going to be
great all right John pick a name hey how
about male Lyon M Lyon my goodness man
you know what I imagine you got for
Christmas this year a special Jewish
surprise from the h bear now I know you
probably haven't heard about the
Hanukkah Bear right been deprived if
you've been following some of these
shout outs you might know about the
Hanukkah bear so the Hanukkah bear uh
you know Santa goes to the chimney
Hanukkah bear he goes to your trash yes
H he goes you know like you might leave
it out once a week for people I don't
know how it works in Sweden maybe you
guys just like throw things out into the
street and then it just magically
disappears you know why imine disappears
that Hanukkah bear is going around town
just eating up all the trash man and uh
I hope the hanuk ver left you some great
presents every night uh day one because
there's eight days in hukah uh left you
a big turd and day two uh left you like
a hairball or something coughed up yeah
then day three a $100 bill can you
believe it and then day four big pile of
piss and day
five other little bears because Hanukkah
bear is a m female and didn't want to
you know take care of any of these bears
and so now they're yours so now they're
yours to take care of but once they get
to a certain age they will Rebel and
murder you so you better get rid of them
fast true and then on day six I gave you
a James Bond collection CU we got to
throw in in there
CU and then day seven they gave you the
new actor who's playing James Bond shows
up right at your doorstep
congratulations you get to meet Finn
wolfard the new James Bond and then day
eight this the new Indiana Jones reboot
comes out just for you cuz he loves
Indiana Jones as well and he was uh is
that the day eight yeah the day eight of
Dy that's better than I was going to the
day eight of Destiny baby you're going
to have so much Cinema and and bodily
fluids to deal with on Christmas I was
on Ra was going up that hill man I was
about to just make a climax about to mic
drop this [__] about to do the flags of
our father's little all four soldiers
planting the American flag right there
type of statue it's about to do Rocky
climb to the top of the stairs fist pump
in the air if I Only Could Make a Deal
With God I'd get him to go back 10
seconds that you could do all that yeah
I had a great great final one to give to
male and now he's never going to know
well how about day nine let's let's add
a day nine not day nine it's not how
Hanukah bear Works say just Willy Dilly
add a day to the Hanukkah bear schedule
yeah that's true I I know I'm just
bargaining I can't accept reality M but
maybe you
can he M thanks for being here Budd we
love
[Music]
okay